[sighs]
Well, none of this will matter
if you don't make
that bloody hammer.
Why can't you just wave
your fingers like a wizard
to raise the dead,
or whatever?
[Hector] The forgemaster
works through an instrument.
That may be the worst
justification
for a man holding his penis
that I've ever heard.
Oh, my God.
And I am 200 years old.
[sighs]
Look...
I am a forgemaster.
I didn't invent the name,
all right?
That's just what they call us.
And the magic has to be focused
through an instrument,
like breath being pushed
through a flute.
This isn't getting any better.
I need the bloody hammer.
Is that better?
So use a bloody hammer.
There must be a thousand
bloody hammers around here.
No, it's got to be special.
[scoffs]
Your special hammer.
[laughs]
Would you stop?
It has to be made from scratch,
in a very particular way,
or else it won't work.
Like a flute with no holes.
Right.
-For fingering.
-[laughs]
Would you stop?
So when you blow it,
nothing comes out.
Good god, woman.
I'm bored, and it's fun
to horrify you.
Indulge me.
And think of something
to tell Carmilla.
She's getting very cross.
Oh, dear. How sad.
Never mind.
Seriously.
You've supposedly been making
your magic hammer for weeks.
Couldn't you make
something simpler?
A stick, or a coin,
or something?
We all use different things.
Isaac used a knife.
A hammer works better for me.
Well, make it work faster.
If Carmilla loses her temper,
I won't be able to stand
in front of you for long.
You'd stand in front of me?
I've been doing it for weeks.
Huh. Yes.
Yes, I suppose you have.
Well, thank you.
I'm working on it.
You know what I'm going to say.
Hmm.
Work faster.
Yes.
Yes, but it needs to be perfect,
or nothing will come out
of the end.
Ugh, you're disgusting.